people talking during the democratic
debate I'm Dave Rubin
I've got Bridget feta Z and this is my
first ever our first ever post debate oh
wow live stream we've never done this
before
CNN and MSNBC and Fox when they do this
it costs the millions of dollars they
bring in analysts people who got
everything wrong last election and
that's the best way to become an analyst
if you get everything wrong each year
they can't you were pretty much that's
why we're doing it all different here I
don't bring in 80 heads now to have I
bring in one person okay knows
everything about everything and we're
gonna talk about what we just saw now I
should be honest with people I did have
a little line during the debate you do
not drink though no no I'm high on life
I'm a debate so so here's what we're
gonna do people I want to talk to that
camera for just a sec so first off we
are taking your questions so if you go
to rubin report comm or if you have the
reuben report app the apple iOS app or
the the google play the Android app you
can submit questions right now we
already have I mean we have literally
like I don't know easily 100 questions
already and we're just gonna kind of
share our thoughts on that thing
Bridget's kind of similar to me in that
she well can I say you're a former lefty
or you're you're mostly a lefty or
mostly someone that thought they were a
Democrat or yeah my whole life until I
became registered independent but I
would say I was also like a leftist in
my 20s right so these people so most of
most of these people are the types of
people that you would have been voting
for and into the ideas that they are
tossing out there much attention to
their ideas I just voted Democrat yeah
and I didn't really watch the debates I
never knew there were those men are like
why is this girl on there never watch I
I feel like there's so many debates that
where there always this many yeah
this many but it seems like it's getting
longer and longer and longer I think
it's always a presidential election
season now year round well isn't it
crazy that just that like the fact that
like we Trump just became president
doesn't it feel like that just happened
how was that three years ago already
yeah just flash-forward and we've
already been talking about this election
for six months yeah and this election by
the way isn't for another ten months
from now or nine months from now mercy
on us we're gonna make it are we gonna
make it by doing this yeah I think that
you know there's people what can go to
like the professionals for their for the
analysts oh they're the professionals no
they're wrong about everything all the
time so if you're gonna listen to
someone guesstimating listen to people
who know nothing who want to make fun of
it all yeah well you could literally
anyone that's watching this right now
you could put on MSNBC right and you can
literally watch Rachel Maddow who for
three years screamed about a Russian
collusion hoax that turned out to be
nothing
yeah I feel think you can put them on
any of the corporate media yeah anyone
really they're just terrible alright but
let's talk about the these six these six
people that we're up there all white all
white people except for Elizabeth Warren
who is 1/1000 24th Native American Bank
wait in the debates has anyone they've
sort of given up on it they just ignored
it or they but no one in the debate has
pushed pushed her on that I don't think
in any of the debates it was brought up
yeah I haven't seen I'm not sure if
that's sure and I but I don't recall
that happening yet which is interesting
you would think someone might say hey
you you lied about being Native American
lied about Native being Native American
to get a job you know what I mean so she
actually stopped the Native American
person from getting into a job this is
the same woman who also she demands that
you know other people's children go to
public school with no school of choice
and no charter schools and you know she
you're not gonna believe this but her
kids go to private school this is like
my neighborhood
yeah in LA there's there's all the like
coexist bumper stickers different places
well and then they recently wanted to
build a place that had housing for like
people who are insects whatever it is
like go away come out income housing and
they all boycotted it that's what they
do well it's nearly not in my backyard
I want homeless shelters on the other
especially in LA it's like throw them in
the valley yeah strange there's no
homeless shelters in Beverly Hills these
lepers are I think they just basically
forced them to let them build the rail
through Beverly Hills and it was because
they wouldn't even let them build the
rail literally to show what hypocrites
Hollywood this whole town really is that
is not a joke what you're just saying
there's no public transportation no rail
no train that will get you to Beverly
Hills because basically the rich people
didn't want all the poor people to be
able to get there right even though they
work for them right they're the
gardener's and the plumbers and all that
is a bribe they didn't want them to be
able to get there on public Treasuries
which is such a perfect example and I
don't think there's any statistical
basis for that fear you there I think
it's a pretty thoroughly debunked to
that crime increases because of public
transportation like if someone wants to
rob you they'll get there yeah you know
doing that I feel like wait for the bus
and they're usually how many people to
rob the house and then get on a bus
waiting for the m17 all the big
robberies that have happened on the way
like West LA they're all getting into
you know SUVs when they're done they're
not jumping on the rail all right before
we go too far into LA crime rates the
fact that it's six white people I know
that you don't care about it I don't
care about it I don't care about whether
someone's gay or black or Asian or has a
limp or a lazy eye or a stiff back or
any of these things I care about their
ideas now pretty much all those people
have pretty terrible ideas Maya Smith
but but yeah in my estimation but the
fact is that now Cory Booker is kind of
implying that the Democrats are racist
now because he's out right and when
Pelosi turned on a Oh
AOC said pulao Caesar racist like
doesn't this all seem kind of obvious
like if you guys were just gonna call
everybody racists and bigots and
homophobes but eventually it would all
come crashing down on you I think - they
all ran all the people who are done ran
on some kind of woke Ness you know they
they ran mm-hmm and it feels like even
just seeing what happened in the UK that
that clearly doesn't work it didn't work
in 2016 I don't understand why anyone
thinks that will work and so instead of
facing that and saying oh maybe running
and I like running on this platform is
not helpful
I feel like they just double down on it
and then lose and then say see that
confirms my belief which is the tricky
catch-22 of that right instead of
looking in the mirror and be like maybe
we're doing wrong here it actually in
their minds it's like oh we are even
more oppressed than we thought or it's
the you're racist you defend yourself
and say how am i racist you even asking
that question is evidence of your racism
right you know how can anybody you can
even argue at that it's impossible such
lunacy all right so we're just gonna do
this
off-the-cuff yeah see what happens I
haven't even looked through these cancel
I'm gonna randomly just kind of scroll
through and just see what we get to some
of these questions came in before the
debate some of them came in dirty as mad
there wasn't more blood they were so
nice to each other there was really
nothing felt muted well that moment when
Tom Steyer turned to people who to
judgment was basically like I have a
crush what are you doing what does Tom
Steyer doing let's just get toms why we
just get Tom Steyer everybody's dick
yeah might be ready to endorse somebody
at any minute well you know you felt
like he was gonna be like and I endorsed
mayor Pete yeah the man didn't he remind
you of just like a kid in like
elementary schooler no no more like
junior high schooler signing seventh
grade lunch table who like nobody liked
but he was rich and you knew if you like
let him sit at the table maybe his
parents were gonna buy you toys like
that are you get to go to the mansion
he's like Oh
what is he doing up there the party that
hates billionaires
yeah he's I'm surprised they didn't all
turn on him and you know I start
devouring him limb limb by limb he I
just I get mad because he's wasting time
you know yeah and that is really we were
joking about this like quintessential
billionaire just up there like I can
beat here cuz I'm gonna waste I
literally he's like I am spending
hundreds of millions of dollars to waste
all of your time and to waste the time
of people who might have something to
say and could get the nomination yeah
it's not it I don't understand how he's
even there it makes it well it has
something to do with he's polling I
guess at 16% in South Carolina that's an
early state so that somehow got him into
this but actually that's a good point
you know the that I would say the two
saner people out of this whole thing now
two of them they happen to have sat in
that very chair that you're sitting in
right now but but Andrew Yang and Tulsi
Gabbard who at least strike me as as
pretty decent moderates you know they're
there's maybe a little more left than
for my taste at this point right but but
I mean I've sat with them I've looked at
either decent human beings Tulsi
obviously loves the country Andrews got
some new ideas they're gone like they're
out there are debates well they could
potentially get back in if you know if
because yeah but in a weird way in a
weird way it's like that's why MSNBC
every time they do a poll they leave
yang out or they accidentally put a
pensioner Jackie Chan it's like what are
they doing I know I didn't really it's
funny how they messed up both their
pictures recently didn't they yeah no
they don't stand a chance we're all sort
of conspiracy theorists at this point
like if you're paying attention you're
kind of a conspiracy theories because
you're like oh this is what corporate
media does to everybody that was
supposed to be Andrew yang is it a
conspiracy theory if it's just true if
it just keeps happening over allottee
yeah all right so wait let's just before
we get to the questions let's just go
through like there are general feelings
about each six of them so we got steyr
out of the way yeah what are you doing
what one of my one of my guys right
before we started they're like what do
you think about that guy
in steer okay all right so yeah just
pointless get out of here ridiculous
just embarrassing yourself even
Bloomberg would be better than him leave
or he buying his rayappa billionaire
that's funny billionaire swap that could
be it's a good idea to do it yeah all
right so let's Tom stires have anyway
there is one person up there I'm gonna
hold this person for a little bit cuz
there's someone that we both sort of
like yeah in a weird way alright but
let's go to let's go to fight in next
byte and you have some interesting
thoughts on I can't I can't
I heart broken when I see him and I
think tonight he actually did better
than I've seen him do before and this is
really a mentally like he actually
seemed a little clearly not talking
about anything he said and the ideas I'm
purely talking about his mental state
and how sometimes I feel like he'll have
that train of thought and then it just
hits like a black hole and then you see
him trying to recover and I feel like
his he's slipping I could be totally
wrong yeah but I feel like he has that
kind of like scared look in his eye
isn't that sad like scary and you know I
think anyone that's been around an old
person I have no idea if he has dementia
or any of these things or the beginnings
of it but everyone's been around an old
person a grandparent or something where
they're beginning to get that thing and
they're talking and you're sort of
praying you're like tense listening to
them because you're praying they can
sort of get to the end and there is that
feeling but he was way better tonight
they also itand him a lot less he looked
more natural he was a little calmer yeah
tonight so has those moments and you can
what what gets me and again this is just
the intuitive feeling I have is that
there's pant he's panicking yeah and you
and you know that feeling you vent you
and I have been on stage when you have
you ever blanked on stage where you just
blank and you're like what the words I
gonna say yeah that is what I feel like
is happening to him but it I don't know
it's it it hurts my heart to watch him
and I don't know why you
actually said something that was really
funny but also deeply depressing during
a debate we're watching Biden and so
most of the audience knows that my dog
am I now she's 15 and a half she's lived
an incredibly wonderful life yeah she's
in her last couple you know we know it's
been we've done everything we can do but
we're getting there but basically emma
was on the floor in front of you and
she's having trouble getting up at the
moment the whole thing and basically
both you could just say what you said
because it was just like she was on the
floor and he was it was one of those
moments where you could see him just
kind of and I was I said watching him as
kind of it gives if it evokes in me that
same feeling I feel when I look at Emma
dodge yeah who's struggling and I'm not
saying that he's near death or anything
by any means but I do have that VOC
something really primal II in me of like
no what are you doing why why are you
doing this yourself so what if I can't
Obama stop him I don't think anyone I
think they all what if whoever the
powers that be are whatever that machine
is I think they said him dude you've got
to do it or or the Socialists win right
and he was like he's been in this
forever he was kind of feeling good that
day and he just said he wants to do it
yeah okay no it's but it is kind of but
so one of the reasons that I like
talking about this stuff is because you
you upfront admit you're not a political
expert you don't have like a know you do
have ideas though right but like but
that you admit that you're not a
political aspirin on these things but
you are sort of intuitive about what
people feel about this do you think
anyone's excited about Biden I mean is
there anyone out there that is like
Biden's the answer right I don't think
it's I don't think they're excited about
him my feeling about Biden is that he's
the only hope which isn't a great way to
go into it's not really stirring
passionate feelings of Brooke yeh and
excitement it's more desperation like I
feel in the same way that he's grasping
when those moments you kind of see
metaphor I feel like that's the it's
like we're just gonna hope that he's the
one right it's funny Star Wars was
called a new hope Joe Biden it could
only hope that's it I guess Joe Biden it
sort of is what it is he's not a
terrible person but he's also kind of
wrecked by woke miss he you know he
tries to out woke them and men can go to
women's prisons if they identify as a
woman just like a lot of this nonsense
so that's--that spider do you think that
he will get the nomination let's hold
that a little bit our some predictions
Elizabeth Warren I just again intuitive
I judge them all based on superficial
things no I
we were we were joking it's okay so gut
instinct initially there's just
something about her voice so she sounds
like she's trying to talk like a man she
always sounds really just trying to come
off like I'm a tough guy or maybe it's
the fear of not sounding shrill or all
the things that women are often accused
of that's interesting cuz she doesn't
sound shrill in like a way that Hillary
used to sound shrill she sounds I mean
what I don't like about her is she seems
deeply inauthentic and unlikable
oh yeah there's rubber that that live
stream I'm gonna get me a beer yeah I'm
gonna get me a beer honey come on us
pull over a stool a or C did a live
stream man it it spurred all these other
people doing us well I always say it
it's like how is it like how did we end
up in a universe where Donald Trump and
orange haired giant boisterous
over-the-top billionaire is genuinely
more authentic than all of these people
like how did that possibly happen yeah I
don't know well I she's a career she's
been doing this long time correct she's
been around the block yeah I don't know
because I just started paying attention
two years ago but she seems like a
practice politician and I don't know
that once you do this for so long I
don't even know if you know how to be
authentic anymore because so much of
being in politics seems like just being
full of [ __ ] all the time
yeah and so how do you ever back off
from that you I do just
lose your authentic self I don't know I
think there's something about these
people that think they have all the
answers for everything like every
question example of this where they ask
any question you know politicians just
make up numbers well we're gonna take
2.4 billion from they all absolutely do
it all they're just make up numbers and
she but she because she comes off as
this librarian that really like read a
book or something she strikes me as
almost like the worst of it because
everything oh we could pay for that
because we're gonna move this year and
we're gonna do this with that thing and
it's like all these plans they never
work they've never worked I also try to
imagine someone like that up against
Trump
so whenever any one of the answering
question he's not gonna take them on he
knows they're 10-point plans that's just
not gonna happen
so how are you how are they gonna even
go up against him if that is their
strategy or is that their only strategy
in in just the in the primary moving
into well it also seems and I think
we're gonna play the clip of this little
did Bernie ever say the woman can't win
but it seems like Elizabeth is in many
ways just a slightly younger female
version of Bernie like what what is the
difference between the two of them right
they want the government to basically do
everything and that's that
Bernie talk about Bernie you were having
trouble eating when Bernie was you were
in the middle of eating because it kind
of spills when he talks yeah there's
drool coming in that lower lip is Hank
yeah he does and again I think it's he
looks didn't he have a heart attack
recently he did have a yeah yeah that's
which is crazy to me because he
literally had a heart attack and I just
think that he um I always joke like I
don't want the olds running the country
I and he looks visibly he was leaning
forward to try and here he does this a
lot he does this at every debate he does
this is that endearing or I don't know
could almost I volunteer laughing in
nursing homes yeah it evokes Oh God also
just like the same like just beating the
same drum forever like it's very us
versus them which again is why I always
actually think he's the only one who
could go up against Trump because
everything is like these people did
these things and and then this is how
we're gonna fight these people seems
like a very well he's the one that in my
mind it makes the most sense to go up
against Trump cuz then it's like we can
just unearth everything yeah socialism
vers capitalism let's do it yeah I mean
it's like thunder go match up I'd like
to see yeah just from a purely
entertainment yeah just from my fiddling
while Rome burns right match up I'm
rooting for ya for somebody that wants
to see the world burn and make some
jokes about it that's probably well
because a lot of people wanted Bernie
because they wanted to bring the whole
system down to and so it's really
choosing yeah which system you want to
bring down what do you think about these
programming system down people like we
live in the greatest freest country in
the history of the world it doesn't mean
that it's the most perfect place ever
there's no such thing as perfection were
flawed so the system's flawed but like
there's no place better than America
nobody wants to leave America and yet
they want it
there's genuinely like I mean the Bernie
people especially on Twitter they're
just endlessly horrific and awful like
they you know these genderless furries
that you know scream about tolerance all
day and tell everyone how evil they are
man I've had them come for me they
probably will after tonight that he
smells like an old home when I watch
[Music]
your with me ain't gonna be pretty
sister but for real like what do you
think about like this like these people
that like it's almost like they're so
bored with success and decency and that
they have iPhones and video games and
like all this stuff but they're like
let's burn it down like burn it down
burn it down is the same it's the same
mentality that you know people are
having lots of home births because we
made
we made maternal deaths and baby infant
deaths we brought that mortality rate
down so now it's something that is we
can have that choice anti-vaxxers you
can choose whether or not you want
vaccinations because we pretty much
eradicated a lot of these diseases
because we have so much privilege and
and so much wealth and prosperity and
good and good they're like burn it all
down yeah like they have nothing else to
do in a way out because of the success I
think it was it's almost like a function
of the success in a certain way yeah I
think it was I on at she she was saying
that we take our freedom for granted
we're like trust fund babies with
freedom it's like three generations down
from having to really fight for our
freedom and so we take it for granted
and so it does seem like we're all a
little bit you know like in the whiney
culture where we're like we need to burn
about down sent from my iphone yeah well
they also love the burn and burn nice
and so we got rid of steyr we got rid of
Bernie we got rid of Joe let's we talked
about Elizabeth Warren oh wait no there
were more there were six right Bernie we
did Warren we did Biden we did steyr
then there's the one that I'm holding
and who's there who's the other one
we're forgetting oh oh so people Murphy
little mayor people so I was joking to
you that during this thing like I kind
of want him to be a little gayer I don't
mean that you know people always say to
me Dave you don't seem gay or something
like that they always mean it as a
compliment I never really take it as a
compliment like I am what I am it's all
that I have why because you don't have
the normal patient association the
effector
they wanna dance more whatever that is
they need to unpack that that's really
that's more on them but when I was
saying it to you like I wanted to be gay
more what I mean really is I just wanted
to be a little more humid he's too young
and like that's seemingly functional to
be so robotic I know like where is the
person in there is there a person in
there well I was saying to you when we
were watching I feel like whenever I
listen to any of his answers I just
imagine him repeating them in a mirror
and if you start watching his answers
and imagine him saying them like in the
bathroom mirror to himself yeah that's
how it feels it doesn't feel like he's
you know there there's no connection you
think that's his handlers like cuz you'd
think that like a young guy like he's I
think he's like 36 that like you'd think
like a young guy who grew up with the
Internet and like he was also in the
military so you'd think he'd be like a
little more like you know like go get
you something like that but he just
comes off as just like you know and I
also I mean just personally I'm not
thrilled with him because you know we
were gonna have him on the show and his
people agreed to it and then basically
attack them and then they backed out of
it and stopped responding to our emails
and it's like man if you're afraid of me
he's like talking about the Ayatollah
forget Trump stand up to Trump but like
he's like I'm gonna tell the Ayatollah
what to do and it's like oh you were
afraid of Dave Rubin you're afraid of
the mob yeah the mob and so I don't know
how you're gonna you think isn't
president you're not gonna deal with a
mob all the time but what do you think
I'm like just overall like he strikes me
okay he's like kinda decent he just
strikes me as a little pretty much
nothing you know just kinda nice
he looked really pretty yeah you much
makeup a lot of makeup yeah using all
the contouring and that was gay how's
that that was pretty good I love the
most part commentary we were just
watching it was just us being like
what's up with her blush would you make
a button there because there are a lot
of weird makeup things like they really
took away Biden's tan this time yeah so
you could see all his like photos in the
first spot
that stuff but that is very weird when
they do that and now with the TVs and
the HD it's like you're I'm even I'm so
I'm like oh God
every single thing yeah every blemish
everything but then when they
overcompensate for that and overdo it it
looks like when the one of the
moderators I think she was from the Des
Moines oh yeah yeah yeah well and he
they were on a split screen and it was
like Hunger Games oh so it was so their
colors and the makeup right it was a
local anchor and people DJ's I think
both had so much yeah there's a capital
in other games do you think there's
anything to him like do you think this
is like a real thing so he seems to
inspire a lot of excitement which i
think is good i I don't know how he's
gonna break through but yeah he needs to
have that breakthrough moment you know I
think he could stand a chance because I
don't sense how he's that different from
anyone else
and so really like a little more
moderate than them yeah well moderate
then say Warren or Sanders his answer is
not always government everything he has
like some element of free market
something okay you know or you have to
pay he said something about cutting
spending at some point or something like
that and it was like whoa you can't say
that to these people but let's talk
about the one who we both sort of I
think she's actually kind of decent
she's obviously not going to be the
President of the United States or win
the nomination but senator Amy Klobuchar
from Minnesota
like and she's trying real hard she put
on a lot of Rouge but she like does seem
to me like somebody that should be in
government yeah and you know fight for
what she believes and it's a little more
big government than my thing but like
strikes me as like a decent person
I think the Minnesota girl in me loves
her and she does seem genuine and also
sometimes nervous which I kind of
appreciate she gets that thing like
Klobuchar syndrome
most of America is yeah most of America
is that's what's funny is that the
analysts are the political analysts they
can analyze all the ideas before put it
in the part most voters are like she's
too much rude so is it all just like
that's what it is it's all the
fifth-grade running for class president
yeah in a weird way in a weird way is so
most people have made up their minds I'm
more interested you know your viewers
seem to be somewhat in in the
politically homeless arena where I exist
I'm interested do those debates change
anyone's mind about who they might vote
for it what I found for most of the
independents I talked to is that when it
when they're faced with the choice
between Trump and a socialist they're
going Trump yeah and so who's gonna
change that vote right so then that's a
bet for basically Klobuchar or Pete or
the didn't or Biden but the two that it
really was well I guess by attenders
really there for that vote but that's
also where yang and Tulsi right would
have done well and we'll see if they get
back in
I miss Marianne yes you love the Chris
and that weird voice of her yeah what is
that accent please tell me I would never
do this normally but I will say this now
cuz she's out of the election but when I
had her on that's right you had her yeah
so when I had her on you know we have
this whole conversation and she's she's
a collectivist like we just have a
fundamental impasse so halfway through
the interview cuz I didn't want to fight
with her the whole time right right like
cuz I try to treat my guest respectfully
so like but like we just view the world
very differently so I was letting her do
her thing but halfway I thought I have
to tell her that we have a difference of
opinion here just so that my audience
doesn't think I'm an idiot or wrong with
her so I said I just want to be clear
you know you're a collectivist you
believe in the group and I believe in
the individual and that's okay whatever
and then we do the rest of the interview
and then it when the interview ended
after she does all this collectivist
stuff and she talks about reparations
and you know she's done this thing where
she prayed she had white people go into
a church and they touched black people
yeah that was that was a great way we
like
crazy stuff but then the second the
cameras went off she turned to me and
she's like you know I'm pretty much a
libertarian too and a lot of what you
say makes sense and I was like lady I
wouldn't really never do that to you I
guess but it's just like I think a
presidential candidate you know what
they say off camera is different just
like a regular you know and then she got
caught on that hot mic on that show
where she basically said the same thing
right where she left these are like far
more evil and there's so much nicer to
me she's just funny they need you to do
that throughout this just be Mary Ann
that so that's Klobuchar so yeah the
shaking things a bit much and also
because she's got all that hairspray so
when she shakes the whole it seems like
a helmets she's so Midwest yeah and I
and I just seems like a decent woman
right like she's she's a wife in an 80s
sitcom or something yeah she just and I
sense that she really enjoys being of
service I actually sent she enjoys being
it's not I don't sense that it's a power
thing for her it does actually seem more
she seemed to go the hardest on Trump
tonight I think maybe she took the first
shot but I was in the can in the canyons
losing signal yeah but she CI she seemed
to keep bringing it back to him which
was surprising because I feel like in
all the other one she has been the most
lenient so I don't know if she just
decided to change tactics er all right
people that is our professional
breakdown of their medical conditions
and other strange personal idiosyncratic
problems okay so we have a zillion
questions here if you want to submit
questions you go to Ruben report.com
just sign in and drop us a note or you
can download the app on iOS or on
Android so there's a million things here
okay well this is this is just like a
general and that's a theme that already
we've hit but how will doubling down on
identity politics work to be Trump I
mean I just don't think it will III
think Trump's probably gonna win in a
landslide short 44 states basically
short of some crazy thing happening that
which you know some crazy ex back
or horrible event could my theory with
him is that the only person who can be
Trump is Trump because he does have like
a bit of a self-destructive wild
tendency which makes it feel very out of
control and chaotic and I don't know who
among them it can beat him but I do
think he could somehow like he could
actually do something so bananas are off
or unhinged I don't know what that is
there was a great tweet someone said can
we fast-forward to the part where he
shoots someone I'm like really and win
still so I'm not sure what that would be
but I don't yeah it still feels a little
bit I part of me is like yeah he's gonna
win 44 states and the other part of me
is like or we'll all die in a nuclear
explosion
well world war three started yes you
know they keep telling us world war
seven why I will say Lawrence I will say
this about Trump that a couple weeks ago
I was in West Palm Beach speaking at
Turning Point and I spoke in the morning
and Trump spoke like an hour or two
later and I've never seen him speak live
before but I was in the second row so
first time I've ever seen the guy speak
live and I noticed one of the
fundamental differences between live
Trump and what you see on TV Trump which
is he's kind of a comic up there right
but when you see only the snippets it
all sounds crazy so like one of the
things he was talking about was was wind
power and windmills and he gets up there
and he goes he goes I know everything
about windows nobody knows more about
windmills than me and then he does this
like 3-minute thing about windmills they
are the shape of the thing and they
don't look pretty and I like windmills
that are there's a and it's like if
you're actually there and you see it
within context you're like he's just
being funny he's making a broad point
about that we waste money you know giant
programs that don't really do anything
in the rest of it but then you watch
them cuz then I was there so I see it
live you know the full hour speech but
then I see the Vox reporter that clips
it and then it's Trump saying I know
more about windmills than anyone and
then the reporters like Trump claims he
knows more about windmills than anyone
and it's like you people are all [ __ ]
okay
everything bananas well this is funny
because we just said this have you ever
any amy klobuchar support or heard of
anyone who's voting for her or even
heard of her - right here yeah alright
I'm team coach all right well here's a
cook there's a couple questions about
who do we think is gonna get the
nomination we'll get to that later
Oh a few people also has some version of
this question what we both think of the
Vince Vaughn situation Vince Vaughn sat
with Donald Trump and they shook hands
and sat and talked for two minutes here
should he be executed I mean what do you
have to do here know what's funny about
that news cycle is that they took a
conservatives tweet who jokingly said
that's fine being cancelled and then Fox
blasted it and said all of these libs
are outraged so then on Twitter we were
all making fun of it yeah
but there were plenty of people that
were outright I don't know how it seemed
like something that was very much
manufactured by the the media and I'm
sure there were people who were outraged
they got outraged about Ellen and yeah
you're not it's that whole like guilt by
association thing that she can't even
shake it what's he supposed to do punch
him in the face Yeah right right you
know it's like he shook the guy's hand
talking you know this is a decent person
yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't be I wouldn't
you know I don't know oh this is this is
sort of interesting well alright but
skip that for a sec we'll do some funny
ones first who do you think was the
master clown of the evening like who
really just sort of well steyr cuz it's
like you're yeah it's like what are you
doing are you married anyone I don't
understand why anyone would run or run
for president ever yeah
that seems like the worst job you gotta
be a sick individual yeah you have to be
a crazy person yeah yeah or born
billionaire who has no friends and it's
just isolated oh this is a good one are
there any legitimate polls that can let
us know who's actually doing well or are
we just gonna hear whatever and I'm
whatever nominee of the demo that's
really interesting because you know you
hear people quote polls all the time
yeah
poles were all wrong last time which I
freaking said I said this I'm like no
one's gonna be honest about this you've
come out and said that these people are
deplorable and that and you said if
anyone votes for Trump there are racist
sexist so who the eff is gonna admit to
even upholster that they're voting for
this person No so basically you don't
trust any of the policies we're
compressing it so it's a sad thing
actually that like you can't trust these
things but but there's no evidence I
think anymore that you can people I
people lie to themselves
yeah I'm probably lying to myself 25 to
75 percent of the time and you can do a
poll and you are a polling expert also
right I am 100% a polling expert yeah
let's see Dave I'd love to hear you and
Bridget teas on where you see each of
our social cultural trends heading and
your honest assessment about how we're
not all about how about how we're not
only incredibly divided but that social
currency behind silence or acquiescence
when it comes to radical left okay I
think I got the rest of this so the
basic idea being that because the left
has sort of gone so bananas and that
everyone is now a deplorable or evil or
whatever that there's just like this
massive layer of people who just are
completely afraid to say what they think
I mean this is exactly what my book is
about what okay so I can't wait to read
your book what's interesting to me
you're quoted as what is interesting to
me and I've been thinking a lot about
this is so someone like myself who's
been like hey you guys aren't really
speaking to me I feel like you left me
at the bar now you're waiting on the
hipsters the response to has generally
been good riddance
so what am I supposed to do what
somebody like I know a lot of people
like me who feel like disenfranchised
lefties but can't just hold our nose and
vote for Trump either it doesn't
really matter because I'm in California
which is a lame loser thing for me to
say but for people where it does matter
I think they're really divided and
confused and torn but if you have if the
if the Democrats are constantly saying
like we don't need your vote okay
they're not gonna vote for you then yeah
and it's not just we don't need your oh
it's like you're an awful human being I
agree with us on everything because
basically you have to agree with them
like there was nothing on stage tonight
that they really had any disagreement
about the one little thing is that Biden
did vote for the Iraq war and Bernie was
against it like that is a fact and
that's a they're gonna bring it up all
the time but that's something that
happened you know 18 20 years ago
whatever yeah it's almost 20 years ago I
mean it's crazy yeah but like in terms
of everything else like there's no real
disagreement there on anything like they
have little like oh my social security
plan I'm gonna make up this number
that's a little higher than your number
and you're gonna do this with your
number and but like there's no real
disagreement I mean is it because they
don't foster a place where disagreement
is sort of allowed right
the diversion that's what I don't
understand really is that what is there
I get the sense of America it's just
been my I just feel my god it's so
cynical it seems so cynical and I'm not
saying you know we're talking about the
Democrats tonight so I I know a lot of
people will be like but you don't say
anything about how the writers cynical I
didn't I didn't know you during the last
election but I'm gonna go out on a limb
and say that you made a gajillion jokes
about all the Republicans just as I when
they were doing it you can find jokes
about every Republican from Trump to
Rubio to Cruz said Trump is gonna win
and I said to the left you guys are
gonna joke him into the White House
because you don't take him seriously and
I kept saying that overnight I mean you
guys left this guy's gonna win the
election and polling expert an election
expert I'm like marianne williamson i
can see the future on crack all right
people what are we doing here i'm taking
your questions which you're submitting
on reuben report calm we've got an
incredible community there of people
good people no trolls it's actually
quite amazing and we've got an iOS app
they are good people and an Android app
and all that good stuff so you can just
search Reuben report here we go ooh this
is this is is the tough one putting us
on the spot
true or false behavior will make Dave
and Bridget consider voting for Trump on
election day I mean the answer for me is
true okay I absolutely will consider it
at this point okay yeah I don't know
that I kept my choice is Trump who I
think is a capitalist he's a you know I
still think I would like take the [ __ ]
way I wouldn't do I don't like to do it
this time
is that really did last time well know
last time I doubted for Gary Johnson
because I'm in California we have a
certain luxury I like I really wanted
just like a libertarian idea to get out
there and I thought if there was ever a
chance for the libertarians I thought
because everyone has so many people
hated Trump and Hillary I thought oh
maybe Gary Johnson could sneak in and
get 5% you know like something I've
heard of and that then would like
proliferate some of the good libertarian
ideas he was just a terrible candidate
and whatever and he's a nice guy and he
smokes too much pot and you know
nobody's perfect yeah but I don't think
I can sit on the fence in that regard
yeah why are you thinking sit on the
fence I just think if you're like too
big of a deal now I just feel like like
I whoa first off you're just generally
speaking I wouldn't have a major problem
voting for Trump okay like I just
wouldn't like do I love everything about
his personality no but do I think
basically the country's in pretty great
shape the economy is crushing it we are
getting out of these wars but I don't
think we're going into World War 3 like
we're I think there's so many good
things
actually happening here I think he's
also the guy that's like crushing
identity politics and while a regular
Republican would have just been
destroyed by it he's calling out the
media [ __ ] don't plays his own
version of identity they support but
this is this is I don't think he's
perfect right the question the question
is would you consider it you know he's
still like fueling petty grievances and
the feeling of like other and us versus
them and well no you're very unifying
one of the things that he does all the
time but I think he should get away from
is he needs to stop making it sound like
he's the president of the Republican
right you know he says we as Republicans
or Republicans this and Democrats this
and whatever and it's like you know we
all fall into that trap sometimes yeah
but that's my true or false answer I
will strongly consider I it's I I'm
still false you know you will not
consider it in this moment as of a
question I don't I can't I there's still
a part of me that just would feel like
it goes against my intuitive sense of so
you think so basically if it was someone
like Bernie why you don't like you you
would vote for the libertarian or you'd
ride somebody in or right right right I
wouldn't vote for Bernie yeah but I
probably vote libertarian I wish there
was a third party I hate the binary
choice I wanted I think there should be
I think we should smash that and I would
love to see a third party break through
I think of any if there could be any
chance it would be now well I crave a
conspiracy theory which all seemed to be
true these days is that this was exactly
what the plan of the progressives were
what the progressive plan for these last
five years or ten years basically was to
sneak in through the through the
Liberals the good liberals because this
was the only way that they could get in
because liberals are nice and tolerant
and we've got a weak underbelly so they
snuck in through us to destroy the party
the Democratic Party is destroyed
because a OC who I think is an idiot and
wrong about everything she actually made
a good point the other day she's like
why am I in the same party as Joe Biden
wow it's like yeah and that's actually
she actually is right you are a radical
socialist lefty that's fine if that's
what you are
Joe Biden is not it shouldn't be in that
party no matter how much he tries to
fake that he's woke or whatever
so it's like you know what I mean like
there's some truth to that that these
people shouldn't be in the same party
but you know once that party splits well
congratulations you've got Republicans
winning forever or years before if a
strong libertarian had come in and it
would have split there the right then
you'd have Democrats forever so it's
it's risky what happens when you bring
in a third party but yes maybe a couple
more parties although a lot of countries
in Europe have tons of parties and they
love these weak systems yeah you know
Israel's had three elections in a row
because they can't form a coalition yeah
I don't know it seemed I don't know I
just wish that there was I don't feel
represented by either party and I don't
think that I'm alone in that so I wish
that there was someone who did represent
that more libertarian feeling yeah
there's no I mean just right now there's
there's just nobody the libertarians
want me to run they do for what I have
yeah they do literally we should run
maybe guess what guys were announcing a
campaign tonight
I told Shapiro if Shapiro ever runs for
president I will be press secretary the
night before the election yeah and Trump
won and then I was running around
because I was this press secretary and I
was in the basement and there was
somebody trying to someone was trying to
assassinate them and I'm like what do I
need to put something out and then
another handler came along and said oh
don't worry Trump does always on press
what a prophetic dream I mean it was
true jeez that is good oh you're gonna
like this one because you are a cultural
critic expert yeah this actually is
right up your wheelhouse what do you
think the next big comedian or celebrity
to take a high-profile whack at the left
will be who has stayed silent so far
that you would have expected to speak up
already personally I wish Seinfeld was
more I was just gonna say Seinfeld
I mean he did say her into colleges
anymore yeah which is his way of
like yeah no I'm not doing that yeah I
always used that one as the example of
how out of control political correctness
is because if you nobody knows
Seinfeld's opinion on anything no like
he's so politically correct no it's
obvious well you know Adam Carolla
wouldn't he was here a couple his theory
is that if you if someone's in Hollywood
and you don't know I've been saying this
forever yeah I got mad cuz I'm like if
they're not tweeting about politics
they're probably libertarian or
conservative but I never tweeted eggs I
didn't want out everyone I feel that too
sometimes but it's like laughs Corollas
doing it he's friends with a lot of
these guys yeah but but who do you think
I mean so we just saw look Chappelle is
now woken up obviously Ricky Gervais
just torched this whole town yeah you
know there's more people like us doing
it at the online level but do you think
there's someone that's kind of like
itching itching to do it it's really
more interesting to me is is there a
female who will do it
yeah really men many high-profile
females who have and I'm not sure that
they could you know who could have done
it but she went the other way and it's
really unfortunate Sarah Silverman well
she really went the other way but she
was always a real lefty like okay to me
it's Whoopi Goldberg Whoopi who is so
brilliant so funny so down with free
speech and any or whatever and yet she's
really taken a turn to the left now I
think it's partly just a visceral thing
with Trump yeah I understand that yeah
yeah that they're there you know I do I
hate the whole like privilege everything
privilege but I do have a certain amount
I have some luxuries that other people
don't so I my experience of the country
and the nation is different which is why
I sure but it's not because of your
whiteness no but I go in knowing your
history and everything else yeah but i
but i but i don't i don't experience i
don't experience things the same way and
i do try to give every individual the
event i believe in individuals so I try
to give every end
benefit of the doubt and understand that
my worldview is not the only worldview
hmm so I I can understand why someone
might have a different verse or visceral
reaction my what's weird and I don't
trust myself always you know I don't
because I'm an addict yeah
and so I'm trained to not trust a lot
and I just wonder did I did the did the
culture move super far left and I was
left behind or is my lizard they're not
even my lizard brainers like some part
of my brain adapting so that I can
survive survive within the madness yeah
just to say well I don't think that the
culture actually moved that far I think
a bunch of loud screaming radicals who
then became journalists and became and
became university professors right so
they taught they indoctrinated a whole
bunch of people and then you've been
just in the last couple days you know
it's like three years ago we were
talking about labeling everyone to Nazi
and why that's bad
then it was you can punch a Nazi and now
this project Veritas video came out
today about this Bernie oh well yeah he
locked himself in the campaign
headquarters because they caught him on
video basically saying you know we're
gonna send people to the gulags and
there's gonna be violence if Bernie
doesn't get the nomination and we're
gonna kill cops and like well
everybody's doing this there will be
violence if they don't get the
nomination there won't be a civil war
I'm like what are you what are you guys
gonna fight over a chick know it
somebody doesn't eat chick-fil-a someone
doesn't eat so it's not what are you
fighting over it's so weird yeah it does
all right here we go where do you even
choose to begin critiquing these ideas
for many of them for many of them are
duh as for how obviously bad or
ill-conceived they are so how do you
technically take these ideas seriously
so they can be dismantled I think we
were both suffering from a little of
that during the debate like so many like
the whole conversation is so like dull
and boring as if these people can solve
all of these problems but it's like
they're not really talking about what's
important I don't know
anyone who thinks the government should
do things but the hook they can do
things better
yeah so I'll talk to somebody who's like
burn it all down or whatever and or
let's read just okay let's just talk
about redistributing wealth
let's redistribute the wealth you'll
talk to somebody about this okay
and who is gonna redistribute it oh the
government oh you're gonna trust the
government I hate the government but
yeah look at California it's a perfect
example of okay we make tons of money in
like we have crap roads and where does
it all go
I might cardi B you know like where's my
money cardi B I'm not even totally sure
who she is but I perish she was gonna be
the governor of Utah area how far into
the debate before you guys decided to
watch reruns of The Golden Girls I would
have that actually would have been very
nice it was basically the Golden Girls I
mean I thought we were watching reruns
well I tweeted out something about how
Biden looks like a guy that would have
dated Blanche Bernie would have dated
Dorothy what's financial fear would
definitely have been a trump supporter
there's no doubt about oh for sure yeah
what's funny is they are how old is
Trump he's old too he doesn't strike me
as that old as that or maybe I don't
know maybe he's fat and like yeah
there's something else going on there
let's see will Democrats who are moving
from blue states like California and
mask to purple or red states like Texas
flip the States permanently blue or is
there a chance their minds change toward
a more moderate view regarding policy I
love this question because when I did
when I toured with Jordan and we did
like a hundred and ten stops over that
over the year you know I was in all
these states that I had never been to in
all these smaller towns in Des Moines
and I was in Salt Lake City and a bunch
of stuff in Texas and everyone basically
was like I would do a joke about ninety
Californians ruining yeah ruining
everything in their movie here and
everyone was like Dave stop telling them
it's good here cuz I would come back and
I do a live stream and I'd be like I was
in Salt Lake City and it was good and it
was great and everyone was respectful
and nice and the economy was booming
get mail from people in Salt Lake like
yeah yeah what do you think these people
ultimately I know it's a real fear with
the Republican Party about success
because they lose Texas their their [ __ ]
out of luck and I know there's a
legitimate fear because it was I just
notice with and it is I don't understand
that it's a crazy lefty lost only by a
couple points yeah to Ted Cruz yeah I
feel like with the general though yeah
you know I think that that I don't know
maybe people I feel like the libertarian
spirit in Texas is so strong it would it
would be hard for me to imagine it being
flipped blue and I don't understand that
mentality of that's what I don't
understand
everybody's bitching about this the the
freelance Wow but hey be whatever maybe
five or something I don't remember the
name of it and they I'll see these lying
threads from people who live in
California and they're there create I'm
like stop voting for these people who do
you think is voting for these lives they
scream about how bad education is years
and it's like yeah well we have been
Democrat run for the last 40 years or a
predominantly vote what do you what do
you think needs to change here why would
you go to another state and think that
that is doing the same thing it's like
wherever you go there you are it's like
it's like if you were trying to convert
somebody to a really bad religion you
know you mean like the religion is like
getting everything wrong did you think
that Joe's teeth might fall out during
the debate I do have that yeah and
Bernie makes the bottom row my dog let's
see go up here Dave I'm sorry I just
don't care I know that sounds rude but
I'd wager it's how a lot of us feel
about the Democrats at this point
Biden corrupt Warren a perennial liar
Bernie a communist tree with downright
evil fruit Budaj edge who is he again
that wasn't I guess that wasn't a
question for us yeah
you are welcome for anyone else that
wants to vent by the way go to Ruben
report.com and vent it will feel good if
Trump is re-elected the San Francisco
Bay Area is going to go completely out
of its freakin mind la is the same what
do you predict might change in the
social and political climate if that
occurs I mean this this keeps getting
back to this idea of like is there
anything that could turn these these far
lefties around second trump presidency
do it well but I do think there's I
think as more people speak push back you
know against and and push back so just
because I push back against as I
mentioned I don't know that I can vote
for a socialist but I and I don't know
that I can hold my nose so I I think is
people like me and other people start to
say hey guys maybe
don't be so crazy you know you see this
all the time on Twitter all the left has
to do is not be been sighs it's all
adventure you're all the left has to do
does not be crazy and they can't do it
and how do you out crazy him how how is
that possible
but yet somehow oh let's lean into the
gender stuff because that yeah that's
going great for you guys yeah like when
someone has to choose between those two
things they're gonna choose the lesser
of they're gonna choose the devil they
know you know it's funny I've said this
to Ben where you know I've debated
abortion with Ben several times and I'm
pro-choice and he's pro-life yeah but
what I've said him several times is
bennett's I'm I'm struggling with
abortion now more and I used to say
twenty weeks and I I'm not gonna say it
right now but in my book I take it a
slightly different position on that
whatever but what I find is my position
is changing a little more pro-life not
because I've been compelled that much by
the pro-life arguments but it's because
the pro-choice people are so bananas
right that it starts making me like oh
they're completely unhinged from but
when you're told
again that's the loudest crazy it crazy
but there's nobody on that stage up
there tonight
except maybe Biden and he's getting
weird with it too that would stop a
woman from
an eight-month abortion but it's so rare
it's just it's like but but if your
policy is basically right tethered to
reality right like I don't know it feels
kind of gross no no I I just I don't
understand it's that whole it drives me
crazy oh by the way Dave Chappelle
endorsed Andrew you know I know okay
we're gonna whip Dave we are a
professional program here we're gonna
throw throw to some video clips what do
you think about that people throw to
some video clips in just a second we got
a couple clips from the debate we'll ask
one more question first what we're
professional very professional let's see
which candidate embarrass themselves the
most for the evening is that they seemed
very very trying to avoid the other now
seemed very safe to me
I think the Internet to it just destroys
everything in that sense because
everyone's so afraid that that one gaffe
is gonna go viral and just tank them
yeah but now everybody is just you know
robotic and safe and and and how are you
gonna go against mr. fly off the scenes
did they know that it's probably not
gonna work against the top guy are these
in any particular order or can I throw
at any of them I'm gonna throw it any of
them so let's go to the one moment that
actually was sort of was sort of
interesting because of what happened
over the last couple days this was
Bernie and Warren because there was this
story that apparently a year or two ago
Bernie leaked that story - I don't know
but it was sounded like a story that
Warren couldn't win because she's that a
woman couldn't win so they talked about
it
in the history of our country so senator
Sanders you're saying that you never
told senator Warren that a woman could
not win the election that is correct
senator Warren what did you think when
senator Sanders told you a woman could
not win the election I disagreed Bernie
is my friend and I am NOT here to try to
fight with Bernie but look this question
about whether or not a woman can be
president has been raised in it's time
for us to attack it head-on
and I think the best way to talk about
who can win is by looking at people's
winning record
so can a woman beat Donald Trump look at
the men on this stage collectively they
have lost ten elections the only people
on this stage who have won every single
election that they've been in are the
women Amy
all right so what's interesting about
that clip is that so this story leaks
like a day or two ago no one in their
right mind thinks that Bernie's
anti-women
right like I got I got all sorts of
problems with Bernie I don't the easy
anyway there's even a video of him
thirty years ago saying that a woman
could be present but that video really
showed how disingenuous elizabeth warren
is because she didn't say that it didn't
happen no brilliant pivot yeah like she
said she goes i disagree disagree with
what disagree with what what are you
talking about did he say it or didn't he
say it was almost like it was her in the
media were planting something on Bernie
yeah was interesting too because it if
it was something that got dumped just
the day before the debate so that then
it got gets brought up at the debates
and then she gets a pivot to oh let's
have a conversation about many elections
we won and now we're talking about women
winning the presidency which isn't even
a real question no no one's no one
seriously like a woman can't be
President I mean maybe there is somebody
yeah to always qualify that otherwise
people will say there's one Bridget
there's one person there's one yeah but
I would say most people in 2020 believe
a woman can be President and can win the
election it's an I think it's a Fanta
lysing to act like you have to I don't
deny sexism is real but I hate when it's
this it's all about sexism and instead
as a woman judge me on my merits and my
ideas and if you don't like the quality
of my character or you don't you know
fair enough Jesus easy there with that
iron Rand what are you doing let's throw
a birdie given a little birdie talk our
infrastructure is crumbling half of our
people are living paycheck to paycheck
87 million people have no health care or
are uninsured underinsured got 500,000
people sleeping out on the streets
tonight the American people are sick and
tired of endless wars
which have cost us trillions of dollars
our job is to rebuild the United Nations
mabry build the State Department make
sure that we have the capability of
bringing the world together to resolve
international conflict diplomatically
and stop the endless wars that we have
experiment gonna get to everyone but
vice president says sort of good things
mixed in with crazy things so like end
end wars like pretty much everyone's
into that and I would argue even that
Trump is even into that but then he'll
say something like we must rebuild the
UN screw the UN the UN's crumbling and
it's like nobody needs the UN the UN is
the is the Legion of Doom remember they
lead you to do them they were the guys
that fought the Justice League they're
terrible they're probably we don't need
them and mostly he also said 87 million
people have no health insurance or are
underinsured so they're all basically
admitting that Obamacare just didn't
work right I don't know what that point
like it would be like just so much so
much of what they run against now is
about health insurance right so like
that was Obama Obama's you know that was
his thing right that was his like blue
chip thing I feel like if I did get
really invested in learning the ins and
outs and intricacies of something it
would be health insurance because I is
fun I it's super fun but I don't
understand it seems like the situation
is [ __ ] right like that I do know
people who have not gone to the ER
because they didn't have a you know they
didn't they couldn't afford it but they
can't turn you down no thank you
people are going broke that is that is
true people are in debt every day I see
a GoFundMe for medical bills like that
these are things that there is something
fundamentally I have cousins in Europe
and and Canada and all over the world
and they're like you guys are ridiculous
so there is something that I think needs
fixing obviously but then I don't know
the first thing about how you go about
fixing it well then they also say crazy
things like with all that being said
that's true that people go broke with
things and you know all of that but then
they say crazy things like you not only
medicare-for-all like it sounds good
everyone will have Medicare so we'll it
will all be good but there doesn't say
anything about quality of care how long
you're gonna have to wait or can the
government actually do things or the
paperwork or all the red tape yeah I
don't know where the money goes so
Bernie had the heart attack right a
couple weeks ago you think he got in you
know he got into the best doctor he's
right within two seconds on his special
Senate plan it's like on Medicare for
all Bernie you're gonna wait like
everybody else
you're not animal and I'm not smart
enough to know all these things but is
it the health insurance companies is
that the hospital's who who is really
responsible for the prices well it's the
health insurance companies basically
it's basically the Hillary what the
hospital's charge well I think it's both
but you'd have put it very least right
now we have some level of competition
right so one of the things when Bernie
talks about Medicare for all he also
wants to get rid of private insurance
meaning you wouldn't even be able to
supplement your own insurance privately
like what right does he have to say to
you you can't just buy additional
insurance right or put more money into
something and their choice yeah well so
many people from other countries come
here for those surgeries too because we
have great doctors and and then I look
at it from another perspective which is
I am a freelance
I've been freelance forever and I have
never had health insurance I've never
had a company pay for my health
insurance any of that absolutely yeah
I've always paid myself just private you
know whatever every year it's gone up
since Obamacare and then I had friends
who were comedians or whatever and
they'd be paying nothing and I'm paying
for them I would get so bad I'm like I'm
free yeah they're just like doing
nothing just not even working yeah and
I'm paying for you so that doesn't seem
fair either I better work for them I was
just willing to wait tables and they
didn't want to do that you know so I
thank you one more let's let's show that
Tom Steyer guy or Tim Steen er
whatever its name let's go tom
other countries and I want to point out
that as we do that we're confronted by
this issue which everyone is talking
about but at the same time there's a
gigantic climate issue in Australia
which also requires the same kind of
value driven coalition building that we
actually should be using in the Middle
East
ridiculousness
I mean there's literally no evidence
that the fires in Australia have
anything to do with climate change
they're arrested I think last I saw it
was there it had arrested a hundred and
twenty eight arsonists Oh also Australia
needs a certain amount of fires to
happen so that it changes with with
forests and what plans I know but it's
like they're just the same coalition you
want the coalition of the Middle East
will be the coalition that will stop the
Australian about the climate there like
there are I might have been mayor Pete
I'm not sure who said it but they said
there are literally tornadoes as a fire
that's supposed to sound anything other
than eyes and there are tornadoes of
fire I'm not denying that there are but
it didn't make it sound as terrifying as
I think he meant to do it sounded when
he's talking about fire tornadoes he's
trying to spin it like he can solve it
that's the thing they keep saying like
but I'll solve the fire tornado like
that guy do you remember the guy who
went viral and he was down he he was
almost the physical embodiment of Peter
from Family Guy and he had the Hawaiian
shirt on and it was during the hurricane
he's like why can't we just get the Navy
out there and they can put some ice in
the ocean why can't they just fly around
and make it we're just saying stuff
we're just gonna do this yeah I think
being in California were a little
desensitized to natural disasters so
yeah yeah you think we're desensitize no
I think that we're like a mires you know
there's a part of well Bernie said the
thing tonight about climate change and
talked about the fires in California
right and he said it's related to
climate change I happened to live very
close I don't to say exactly where but
all the fires that people have seen
lately I live in very much proximity to
that one of them was started about a
quarter of a mile down the road at
Bernie's screaming at the car the
California fires are climate change it
was a homeless encampment right right
they don't want to talk about that
what's weird about the fires in
California is that they'll be burning
and everyone will just be driving or
just drivers as usual
so I think that yeah yeah all right
we'll do a couple more and then I think
we'll let the good people go why doesn't
anyone bring up that Russia conspiracy
anymore what happened to that thing it's
kind of funny
migrant Germans yeah I swear this is
we're coming what happened to those my
creme caramel like we are living in a
simulation because then it just
evaporates yeah it's like they're coming
and you're like oh my god all these
people and the caravans like poof
disappear gone Russia disappear gone
right yeah did the caravan turn
alright here's here's one okay because
you are intuitive hmm how do we heal
some of the divides and bring trust back
to our society especially with media
bias oh gosh I mean that's a that's a
lot to unpack how do we try it what was
the first part of the how do we how do
we bring trust back to our society and
heal the divide okay so healing the
divide I think starts with the
individual you know we I had I did a
great interview with Pamela press key
today and she's talking about she's
writing a book the habits of the free
mind psychology for democracy and she
did a lot of the research for the guys
who did the coddle the coddling of the
American for Jonathan Haidt know and so
they had the three great you know
untruths and she has kind of the
antidote in the habits of the free mind
which is she said courage curiosity and
compassion and I really loved that and
Chloe Valerie does a great job talking
about you know not seeing everyone as
the other that us-versus-them trying to
be curious so critical thinking we were
talking the other day about who's your
trusted new sir so part two of that
question with the media bias I don't
they thrive off this division yeah
they're they're profiting half of it you
know that that that how do you how do
you that I always think it Jonah
Goldberg who's just saying to me there's
no money and nuance kid yeah I mean the
best example I can think of that if
Peter for like just is like an easy
personal one for me but a couple months
ago remember
there was that like thing online there's
suddenly this new like frog white
nationalist group oh yeah I know where
doesn't even matter to get into there
but we knew that they were going to a
bunch of events where Shapiro was
speaking at charlie kirk was speaking
and i was speaking in a few other people
so i did this event at sacramento state
and there were it was about 300 people
there and they were probably bout like
30 or 40 m in the crowd and i could tell
because they sit there and they're very
angry
and they have Rumple crumpled papers in
front of them cuz they're ready to get
to the mic at the end and and local news
was there because they were expecting
all hell to break loose right but I gave
a great speech and then during the Q&A I
made sure to let each one of them go up
first I said if you ever disagree with
me you come at first and I answered all
their questions directly and I you know
I didn't mock anybody or momma blah and
then local news didn't do anything with
the story right because there's because
there's no story in that effect so then
so had all hell broke loose had someone
thrown something at me had I had I
fought with somebody had there been a
riot it's the lead story to CNN but
because something good and mature and
decent happened it doesn't make any news
nobody hear anything about it not only
that but then the look I I asked the
news people because they had the full
video the entire thing I said could I
have the video will credit you can I put
it on my channel just to show people a
good example of how to do discourse they
were like so it bleeds it leads
yeah so that's sort of like how do you
how do you heal that it's like I don't
know the economic incentives have to
change related to media and I'm guilty
of it it's so fun you know there's a
part of me that I I can't sit here and
say that I don't take potshots of the
lever I'm constantly making fun of the
lefties and though and the magaz like I
definitely fuel some of the fire myself
so maybe I have to do a little bit of
some inventory your show is called the
weekly dumpster fire is mayor Pete a
match with senator Sanders for a heart
transplant that's a good one
because wouldn't that be something you
take the heart of Pete and you put it in
the old bones that doesn't seem fair to
Pete that doesn't seem fair to Pete all
right I guess we're not going to do that
no let's see
we'll just do a couple more here
thoughtful ones yeah alright the
thoughtful ones so there's there's a lot
I mean this tells you a lot about my
audience but it's a lot of basically I
would I would say our former lefties who
are just saying will it ever end will it
ever end will it ever end you know well
the craziness of the left will it just
ever end
someone said tell Bridget I was just
joking when I said that her Fantasyland
post was the worst advertisement ever
insider thing for you but your member it
was with those people thank you for
clarifying that yeah let's see because I
posted a picture of hope why is it that
the school system is a never is never a
real and big political topic when we
know that there's may be no second
mechanism with such a huge and deep
influence on the future of deciding you
know it's interesting well they talked
about education one of the things that I
always say is that Bernie wants free
college for everybody it's not because
he wants everybody to be equally
knowledgeable about everything or truly
learn about everything it's because if
you ever wanted to get people
indoctrinated leftism where would you
send them yeah you'd send them to
college especially if you're gonna state
fund the college you'd send them there
so he wants them and this video that
Project Veritas just put out of one of
his campaign people that's what the guy
was saying we're gonna have to send I
mean he was saying it in some sloppy
language but basically saying after
Bernie wins we're gonna have to send all
these Nazis meaning people who don't
support Bernie to college like region
camps to learn how to not be Nazis oh my
gosh yeah that just gets thrown around
so loosely did you see Joe Joe Rabbit no
it was so good it was so well done they
came out and said it's a satire it's
about a little young Nazi kid and it I
don't want to give it all away it's
brilliantly done but it really mmm it
makes it reminds you who the Nazis were
and what happened and just I we all joke
about it so loosely now and it's it's
it's so it's
crazy how that has become such a that
words been flattened to blast sound
meaning as so many other words well
especially also because the people that
used the word not see all the time are
the same people who scream about
cultural appropriation all the time and
right so it's like you don't want people
to have a certain haircut because that
might offend somebody but you can you
can joke or you can just label anyone
you want a Nazi I grew up around
Holocaust I had a lot of Holocaust
survivors that were in my family or that
were friends of the family that I knew
and it was like I know fortunately not
firsthand but I know I know secondhand
what that thing is and then these great
literally calling me a Nazi it's just
throwing around like trumpets hell it's
it's very disrespectful to a Jewish
grandchildren entire thing yeah it's all
kind of gross
alright one more should we do one more
one more let me see a good one here
I like this you do like this it's on the
fly this is real yeah we have no if'
bees there's no people abusers screaming
in our in our to be over Dave I need
that hundred seven hundred percent of
the Jarrod's please cancel just to make
your resume two jobs in the port calm
okay here's this is a good one and then
by the way guys there there are a
million great questions here and I'm
sorry that we obviously couldn't get to
everything and I will try to personally
go in and respond to as many of these as
I can tomorrow and over the next couple
days okay so the big question ten this
whole thing is who do you think out of
those people if it's one of those people
gets the nomination I think it's Bernie
do you think it's Bernie so you think
we're just that's where this is all head
up this is all headed to just sort of
rise of Skywalker like goodness the
light versus the dark good versus evil
right
I hope socialism bursts capitalism like
it just that is that well right now from
my energetic Marianne Williamson a
little bit it feels like it feels like
Bernie has momentum
right now and it feels like he's got the
the the thermals are lifting him you
know that mmm and honestly he's probably
the only one who could beat him if
anyone can beat him at all I really do
think it's probably only Bernie I don't
I don't see any of those other people
being able to compete - go ahead - how
do you mean just purely on stage and
well just know also I think with
independent well maybe not know
independence but still there I don't
know I know what you mean on some of the
burn at all down vote that will matter
people who just might says he so an
independent I think someone who's more
moderate might get those independents
who are on the fence and they can't
stomach it so then they vote Democrat if
it's a moderate Democrat but I think
Bernie could get that I'm sitting this
shitshow out vote to come out and I also
think you know else thinks this Trump
because he's been taking potshots at him
Adam left and right I think a lot in the
past week last couple days I think you
lady senses that was so like Oh Bernie's
got the momentum used to be you know
it's like we talk about momentum and
then it's like then we have this the
first Iowa caucus and then suddenly some
weird thing happens and then like calm
stires president or tom ding-dong
whatever his name is but yeah my god
your guy well my gut feeling if you're
just doing like the momentum right now
like where is the energy it's Bernie for
sure
I first you know just knowing the way
the DNC is and how corrupt they are and
how the machine works like they're gonna
push Biden's old bones across the finish
line that's what my general gut would be
but I will throw out one other crazy
conspiracy theory okay I think I put
this on Twitter but I've never said it
on the videotape which is that I think
Bloomberg the only reason he's running
people think he's running to destroy
Trump but Bloomberg's running on the off
chance that that Bernie or Elizabeth
Warren but more more so Bernie if he
gets the nomination Bernie Bloomberg
then runs
to get all of the decent liberals and
the disaffected just the people that
don't want to be socialists thus causing
Trump to win because at the end of the
day Bloomberg is still a capitalist and
he would rather have Trump that Bernie
that's a that's a pretty weird twist on
the way people are talking about this I
think there's anyone from from Trump ya
know you don't pull any Trump people but
you'd get a certain amount of New York
liberals some old-school liberals you'd
get it you'd get some Republicans maybe
you don't think you would pick up maybe
some never Trump errs okay something
like that but you lose the entire base
but even if you then get 6% or even if
you get 4% you probably ensure that
Trump wins and at the end of the day he
wants to live in a capitalist society
versus Bernie yeah do you think that
more people have that Trump has picked
more people up YC you think from then
tonight yes yes without question I meet
so many people that like I'm talking
about like regular people yeah that if
you get them talking a little bit
suddenly you're like oh you two there's
a there's like a underbelly of
libertarianism that's starting to and
and even republicanism that's becoming
more open yeah because you so you hit
this before but it's like if you
literally if the election comes down to
do boys have penises and girls have
vaginas and one piece person says yes
and the other one says no it's like most
we learn about for the yes right you
know as stupid as this it's it's I think
it's physiological you know I think it's
something it's like a people have a
biological or some kind of physical
response to that it's primal they're
like no that one that is he you have any
other sage wisdom before we shut this
thing down
no thanks for having this was more
worthwhile than CNN well I have no doubt
that it was worth worthwhile in CNN but
like this was this was honest real stuff
from from people are trying to make some
sense in the madness and
I think that is more valuable in a lot
of ways that I have a lot of questions
most of the questions out here were from
you to be which was a little odd we'll
deal with that but for real we do a
bazillion questions on here and I
promise you that I will respond to as
many as I can maybe bridge it will jump
in there as well perhaps Bridget has an
announcement coming oh and the guests on
the Rubin report next week is it's me
Bridget fantasy where you can't get
enough of a real world world all right
thanks for watching everybody we're
gonna do more of these and another thing
I'm thinking about doing if you're
interested is we have an ability now to
Skype in for people at once in boxes and
I was thinking maybe we could start
doing some live call-in shows and some
other interesting stuff so this was just
a little test this week and seeing how
the community worked and I think
everything worked out well hope you
enjoyed it and we'll see you later
[Music]
[Music]